what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
spider-man spider-man no way home
continues to crush it at the box office
and right now there are a ton of reports
about new spider-man movies coming not
just with tom holland spider-man but
with andrew garfield spider-man and
possibly toby mcguire popping up again
sometime down the road but today i want
to talk about possibly the biggest
question that a lot of people had after
spider-man no way home one that has
caused quite a bit of confusion with the
community and the audience and that
question is why did everybody forget who
peter parker was entirely in spider-man
knowing home and not just forget that
peter parker was spider-man now the
movie did answer this but with this
answer came a lot of other questions but
the writers have recently opened up in
an interview with variety and have
addressed some things that happened
off-screen
but have happened nonetheless that kind
of explained the dynamics of that final
spell that doctor strange cast and how
it exactly worked and that's what we're
going to be talking about in today's
video so if you love spider-man and want
to stay up to date on all the recent
spider-man and mcu news be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos so the first thing that we
have to talk about is the actual spell
that doctor strange did because some
people think that this is the same spell
that he was going to do originally to
make everybody forget that peter parker
was spider-man that was what was
originally supposed to happen but at the
end it is a very different spell and
they fully explained this in the final
scene where doctor strange says they're
starting to come through and i can't
stop them peter says there's got to be
something we can do can't you just cast
the spell again the original way before
i screwed it up but then doctor strange
replies we're too late for that they're
here they're here because of you and
this right here is where the spell
actually changes from what it originally
was in the beginning of the film peter
says what if everyone forgot who i was
they're coming here because of me right
because i'm peter parker so cast a new
spell but this time make everyone forget
who peter parker is so he asks doctor
strange to make everybody forget who he
is not make everybody forget that peter
parker is spider-man but make everybody
forget peter parker completely he says
make everybody forget me and then they
further clarify this where peter says it
would work right and doctor strain says
yeah it would but you gotta understand
that would mean that everyone who knows
and loves you we
we'd have no memory of you and then he
says the final defining moment of the
spell where he says it would be as
though you never existed and then of
course in a very true peter parker
moment perhaps the most peter parker
moment that tom holland has ever been in
his trilogy he says i know
do it putting everybody else in the
universe really before him and then of
course he leaves doctor strange casts
the spell and nobody knows who he is not
mj not ned not happy nobody like doctor
strange said it would be as though he
never existed but how could this
actually be because you have to imagine
that ned has to have at least hundreds
of pictures of him and peter on his
phone same with mj they have to have
pictures together she has necklaces and
bracelets and trinkets that peter gave
her they just went through this whole
final battle on the statue of liberty
where they literally saw peter how is
there no possible way that they don't
know who peter parker is how was peter
erased from their phones how was peter
erased from pictures actual physical
pictures that they might have had in
frames in their houses well the writers
for spider-man no way home and of course
they wrote spider-man homecoming and far
from home as well kind of give us an
explanation of everything that happened
at the end in an interview with variety
and i'm going to go over the entire
section of this article right here that
is titled the problem with memory
canceling spells i'll go over this so
you can hear exactly what they said word
for word and then i'll explain what
happens at the end of spider-man no way
home now this first part i actually
really like because they talk about tom
holland's peter parker becoming closer
to the comic accurate peter parker this
section begins by saying may's death was
a step in the filmmaker's mission to
strip everything away from holland's
peter and leave him by the end of noah
home much closer to his true comic book
origins a scrappy kid with almost no
resources beyond his intellect and
superhuman abilities that culminates
with his decision to repair the widening
rift in the multiverse by having strange
cast a spell that makes everyone
everywhere forget him as peter parker
now right off the bat they have to
establish everywhere because everyone is
coming from other universes to his
universe so when they say everywhere in
this article they mean everywhere not
just in the main mcu timeline and
universe but in all of the other
universes as well but the writers
actually admit that there are a little
bit of problems that come with this
decision the article continues to read
since holland's peter still exists in
the mcu his decision has a litany of
wide-ranging and persnickety problems
attached to it does this mean all
records of him are gone too does he
still have a social security number are
the photos of mj and ned gone from his
phone and so on which are the questions
that all of us have and here's what
writers eric sommers and chris mckenna
had to say about this in truth the
filmmaking team talked at length about
the implications of the anti-peter spell
and how the movie could address them we
were like do we do a back to the future
kind of thing where you see him fading
out of photos does he still have a
driver's license or passport it just led
to more questions so we decided let's
try to do it in the most satisfying way
and we can just focus on the emotion of
it and then if people have questions
about some of those details that didn't
get answered here we'll answer them
hopefully in another movie somewhere
down the road obviously some sort of
magical redaction has occurred at the
end of all of this we didn't want a lot
of people trying to do magical math in
their head they then say that executive
producer amy pascal suggested looking to
the 1978 warren betty comedy heaven can
wait for a solution people had these
experiences but they start forgetting
the person they knew but they were still
affected by the events that happened
mckenna explained they then explained
that the final donut scene was the most
important thing to focus on mckenna says
you want to have that donut scene be him
making the last piece of the sacrifice i
could tell them everything i can try to
get my friends back but i'd be going
right back to the place of endangering
my loved ones by bringing them into my
life and i can't have that and i
personally love that that happened
because that is true peter parker true
comic spider-man so although the writers
didn't really want us to be doing the
math on all of this that happened we are
because we have all of these questions
but luckily for us they kind of do
explain their thinking they mentioned
that they talked about doing a back to
the future style of memory erasing where
peter just kind of got erased from
photos this also happened in harry
potter where hermione made her parents
forget who she was she kind of just
faded away in all the pictures that they
had and we can assume that this is
pretty much what happened in the mcu the
writers talked about showing it and
although they didn't they do explain
that this is essentially what happened
they only didn't show it because they
wanted that final scene where peter
makes that final sacrifice to be the
focus of it all but it is clear that
peter has been erased from everything
even at the end we see him with a ged
book this means that peter parker has
been erased from the records of his high
school magically his name disappeared
from all records of him magically his
pictures that he took with his friends
he just disappeared from those pictures
all memory and evidence that peter
parker ever existed like doctor strange
says has been erased now how is he going
to go forward without a social security
number and passport and such things like
that well that's something that is
definitely going to be explored in the
next film the writers talked about how
they would indeed address that in the
next film and recently marvel studios
and sony came out and said yes we are
indeed working on the next spider-man
film with tom holland so another
spider-man movie with tom holland is 100
confirmed in which tom holland's peter
parker is going to have to deal with the
repercussions of that spell of peter
parker essentially being erased from
existence which will be interesting to
see but for those of you who were
wondering about this spell and what has
happened to peter parker nobody
remembers him and it looks like there is
no trace of him to be found anywhere
he's not in pictures he's not on
transcripts for schools there's no
social security number peter parker has
been erased essentially from every
single person's mind any type of
database and any type of paper trail in
the mcu i hope you found this video
useful don't forget to subscribe for
more spider-man and mcu videos so you
can stay up to date on everything don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof